the Sony spider-verse right now is a
little bit of a mess Madam Webb is
coming out soon and you might have heard
that apparently they originally planned
for Andrew Garfield Spider-Man to be in
the film but then they wanted Tom
Holland Spider-Man to be in the film but
then they realized that they got some
timelines mixed up and then they
couldn't put anything about Spider-Man
in it at all according to some insiders
Spider-Man really isn't mentioned he's
kind of hinted at and there is a famous
Spider-Man line Dropped In in there
except it's kind of reversed according
to The Insider cryptic HD quality the
new line is going to be when you take
responsibility you will gain powerful
abilities according to the same Insider
the line was then changed to when you
take on the responsibility great power
will come changing a classic Spider-Man
line still no Spider-Man in the movie
but one thing is for certain Sony will
continue to make Spider-Man films
whether it's about Spider-Man
specifically or spin-offs and they are
basically doing both with a new project
that is reportedly in development right
now over at Sony According to some
insiders Sony is developing a rated R
movie focusing around a Spider-Man
character this is believed to be an
animated movie and it's believed to be
about spider punk out of all of the
projects that they could have done this
is probably the most exciting project
that we've got from Sony in a pretty
decent time and if you are not aware
Sony does have somewhat of a plan for
what they want to do with their
liveaction Sony spiderverse and their
animated spiderverse there has been
talks of the two universes crossing over
especially sent Spider-Man across the
spiderverse where they essentially
showed us the spiderverse the Multiverse
now there are talks of the spiderverse
bleeding over into the MCU since the MCU
is in the Multiverse Saga right now and
the tree that they showed in across the
spiderverse seems to be really really
similar to the ell tree that Loki
created at the end of Loki season 2 that
is certainly exciting but they're also
about to dive deeper into the web of the
Multiverse with Madam web according to
insiders Madam Webb exists in its own
universe meaning it's not the universe
that Andrew Garfield is in it's not the
universe that Toby Maguire is in and it
is most certainly not the MCU which Tom
Holland is in but according to V scooper
and cryptic HD quality Madam web will
essentially show us these spider-verse
timelines in the form of a web they
State Madam web enters a realm similar
to this showing this picture called the
web she can use it to see the future and
be in more than one place at once it's
probably the spider verse timelines in
the form of a web now even with this
knowledge a lot of people are stating
that they don't really want Madam web to
connect to the animated spiderverse what
they would really like is for beyond the
spiderverse across the spiderverse into
the spiderverse to connect to the mcu's
Multiverse which again could very well
happen but what Sony is really doing
here is establishing the Multiverse on
their side they've already done a great
job with that with the into the
spiderverse movies and now it seems like
they are attempting to do it in live
action and one thing that they are going
to do now it sounds like is they are
going to Branch off from the into the
spiderverse movies and now they're going
to make spin-offs of characters from
that franchise which makes sense because
that is by far the most successful
Spider-Man related project outside of
Tom Holland Spider-Man and the MCU that
they have done and as far as characters
to pick to get their own story outside
of Miles Morales and spider Gwyn I think
spider Punk is a great choice I think he
was a fantastic character and across the
spiderverse it's also a very different
character than a lot of people are
really used to and the fact that it is
reportedly going to be rated R means
that they could really make a pretty
Killer movie and give him all the
attitude that he deserves to have now
this report is coming from The Insider
my time to shine hello that Sony is
making an animated rated R film once
this news came out a lot of insiders
started posting Gifts of spider Punk
Alex Perez from the cosmic circus is one
of them widely making the internet
believe that this is indeed going to be
a spider Punk rated R movie and it has
fans excited because we could see what
spider Punk was up to in his Universe
what his Universe actually looks like
and we might even dive deeper into the
relationship that he's had with spider
gwy this certainly is an interesting
idea and I will certainly watch this but
we have reason to believe that the
spiderverse and the Multiverse kind of
on Sony's part is about to get a lot
bigger they're about to dive a lot
deeper into it Alex Perez recently
posted on Twitter everyone always asks
the wrong question about beyond the
spiderverse instead of asking when it's
coming out you should ask what lies
beyond the spiderverse he then stated
the answer to the previous question is
the spot well we know the spot
discovered essentially the Multiverse
now keep in mind that everything that
we've seen in into the spiderverse and
across the spiderverse has been
Spider-Man focused the universes have
all been about a Spider-Man variant or
iteration essentially involving the
spider verse specifically the Multiverse
however could involve other aspects now
meaning they could go over into other
universes that may not have a Spider-Man
iteration or variant in them this could
be Craven the hunter it could be Madam
web or it could even be the MCU and keep
in mind Sony has already confirmed they
are doing a liveaction Miles Morales and
a liveaction spider Gwyn they have a
really shared any details about them but
they have said that that's in
development right now this is coming
directly from Amy Pascal an executive
producer again they haven't really given
any details about this but insiders have
come out and stated that Miles Morales
is planned for the MCU and a lot of
people are wondering if this is going to
be the same man from the spiderverse the
animated spiderverse some fans are even
asking if what lies beyond the
spiderverse is really the MCU
specifically for Miles Morales because
this kind of links back to a theory that
I've had about the reboot of the MCU and
a lot of people have been having this
Theory as well since we know it's not
going to be a full hard reboot a restart
of the MCU only a soft one and
characters who have been in the MCU are
going to remain but not all of them and
new characters are going to come in as
well that means that universes could
Collide in Avengers Secret Wars so post
Avengers Secret Wars when the soft
reboot happens the new MCU that we have
the main timeline could be a universe
that consists of many different
universes so what if Marvel and Sony
decided to fuse together another
extremely successful Spider-Man Miles
Morales from the animated spiderverse
and before you think this is too crazy
keep in mind this is essentially what
they did with Tom Holland Spider-Man
Sony was going to make The Amazing
Spider-Man 3 with Andrew Garfield in
fact how Spider-Man came into the MCU
all started with with Amy Pesco calling
Kevin feige over their old colleagues
who worked together for a while asking
for his help for Spider-Man 3 and Kevin
feige said you can't do it it's not
going to be successful let the MCU do it
let me do it it'll be better and we'll
both have massive success and that's
eventually what happened they did have
massive success with Tom Holland
Spider-Man in Captain America Civil War
then homecoming then far from home and
no way home Sony saw more success with
Spider-Man than they have ever had in
the past and what if they're looking to
do that again now the split would
obviously be very very different and
they would not abandon the animated
spiderverse altogether but keep in mind
there are many many many different
universes in the spiderverse and the
universe that Miles Morales comes from
is only one universe and Sony is
probably thinking that they could really
cash in on Miles Morales by moving him
into live action having him be a part of
the MCU like Tom Holland Spider-Man and
have even more crazy amounts of success
while at the same time maintaining the
animated spiderverse maybe focusing on
spidergwen and characters like spider
Punk with these spin-off movies it's
certainly a possibility and I do think
that fans would really love to see a
connectivity between specifically the
animated spiderverse not necessarily the
spiderverse as a whole from Sony but the
end the spiderverse films that we have
come to know and love they would love to
see that Crossover with them and the MCU
but let me know your thoughts about all
of this in the comments down below if
Sony makes a rated R spider Punk
animated movie would you watch it and
would you like the animated miles to
cross over into live action in the MCU
leave your thoughts in the comments down
below don't forget to like this video
And subscribe so you can stay up to date
on all things in the MCU and of course
over at the spiderverse at Sony and if
you subscribe and leave a comment you
are entered in our giveaway for a chance
to win an Xbox series X A PS5 some
Marvel Legends items and some DC items
the winner picks one item and we pick
one winner at the end of each month you
can find us on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof